♪♪
Cuban:
There's a freedom that comes
with being an entrepreneur.
There's a sense
of empowerment...
Whoo‐hoo!
...that you can't get when you
work for somebody else.
[ Screaming ]
Lori, you have a deal!
Yeah!
Greiner:
From day 1, I knew I never
wanted to work for anyone else.
I wanted to be the ruler
of my own destiny
and take my life
into my own hands.
Yeah!
Herjavec: Freedom is the ability
to control your own life.
No one can fire you. No one's
gonna tell you what to do.
It's all up to you.
I'm gonna make you rich.
Watch it happen.
One great idea is power ‐‐
the power to set you free.
[ Chanting "Shark Tank!" ]
Narrator: For over a decade,
"Shark Tank"
has been in the business
of inspiring entrepreneurs.
Scrub Daddy will be scrubbing
in every kitchen in the world.
Narrator:
It's launched household names
and hugely successful companies
totaling over $6 billion
in retail sales...
Welcome to Maine!
...and made life‐changing dreams
come true.
It's a deal.
We're super‐grateful to be able
to continue our dad's dream
and to share our story
with people all over the world.
And tonight...
♪♪
Man: Let's get this!
Come on!
...we're back, with a brand‐new
season of dreamers
seeking to change their lives.
This is our everything.
We're gonna
take this to the moon.
Let's face it ‐‐
I'm only 10 years old.
I need a partner.
Oh, my God, I love you!
I think you're more
of a Shark than we are.
So, that made me choose
creativity over certainty.
I have one wild,
precious life, right?
Narrator:
And tonight, Daniel Lubetzky,
the visionary founder of Kind,
which has revolutionized
the healthy‐snack industry,
joins the Sharks.
I resonate
with your immigrant story,
with the power of America.
Cuban:
If you put your mind to it,
anything is possible.
You are freedom.
Narrator: Which business
will be the next big idea?
This is my life.
I will go until it succeeds.
You need cash.
Says the guy who's not giving
him a dime!
Wait, wait,
may I please finish?!
They're gonna walk out of here
without a Shark.
Welcome to our very
dysfunctional family.
[ Laughter ]
If that's not the American
dream, I don't know what is.
‐Let's get started!
‐Let's go!
Narrator: The future...
I can make you rich.
There's no doubt
in my mind.
Whoo!
‐Wait, wait, wait, wait.
‐It closed.
‐Let me ‐‐ Let me ‐‐
‐Bye!
‐...starts...
‐Go, baby!
‐Ohh!
‐...now!
‐Holy smokes!
♪♪
Wow!
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an eco‐friendly version
of a household staple.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Sarah.
And I am Syed.
And we're here
seeking $270,000
for 2% of our company,
Blueland.
Wow!
Sharks, this is what
an average household
uses in one year
in cleaning products.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Bottles clattering ]
♪♪
And many of these products,
they're over 90% water,
which means
that you're overpaying
for plastic packaging
and a ton of water.
Both: This is such a waste!
Which is why we created
our revolutionary
eco‐friendly brand, Blueland,
where we've turned this...
into this.
So now your pantry
can look like this.
How does it work?
Simply fill your bottle
of water, drop in a tablet.
Minutes later,
you're ready to get cleaning.
And our tablets come with
a beautiful,
reusable Forever Bottle,
so you never
have to throw away
another plastic cleaning bottle
ever again.
Hmm.
Together,
we can eliminate
approximately 5 billion plastic
cleaning bottles each year.
So, Sharks,
let's save money and space
without the plastic waste.
Bam!
We have samples
to pass out.
So, please take
the hand soap.
This one?
Yep. For you.
And then take
a tablet of that, too.
Do you have anything
with packaging?
Yes, we have a wrapped tablet,
as well.
And I can
bring around more.
Is it one product cleans
all windows and surfaces,
or are there multiple products,
multiple tablets?
Yeah.
So, we have four products.
We have
a foaming hand soap
and we have
three cleaning sprays.
That includes a multi‐surface
cleaner, a bathroom cleaner,
and a glass
and mirror cleaner.
So, Sarah,
what do I pay for it?
Our starter sets,
which include one bottle
and one tablet,
that costs $12.
And our Essentials kit,
which includes one hand soap
and three cleaning sprays,
that retails for $39.
And what's a refill cost?
One tablet costs just $2,
which is unequivocally cheaper
than going out
and buying a full,
new plastic bottle of cleaner.
And what's your background?
Are you a chemist?
I went to Harvard
for undergrad.
‐'Course you did.
‐I majored in economics.
After that,
I worked in private equity.
And then I returned to Harvard
for business school,
but I actually ended up
dropping out
in my first year
to pursue my first startup.
So, you're a total slacker.
[ Chuckles ]
My first startup
was a mobile shopping app,
and I ended up selling that
to one of the world's
largest shopping search engines
at the time.
‐Wow.
‐And, Syed, what about you?
I actually was born
in Pakistan.
I moved here
when I was 10 years old.
I grew up here.
My parents
both passed away.
Sorry.
That was
a difficult thing.
I'm the youngest of nine.
I have seven sisters.
I graduated
from University of Pittsburgh
with my chemistry degree.
Most recently, I was
a Director of Foreign Relations
at one of the world's largest
nontoxic cleaning companies.
We are all aware of the problem
with plastics.
We're trying to do
everything we can
to not destroy our planet
before it's too late.
What's your unique selling
proposition or differentiation?
So, we have really formulated
these products
to be really,
really effective.
And, again,
I come from huge companies.
We know ‐‐ I know how
to formulate these products
better than, like, the normal,
traditional chemist.
Come on, Syed.
Look ‐‐
So, the premise is,
you have the one guy
in all the world
in chemistry...
‐[ Chuckling ] Yeah, right.
‐...that made a better product.
Lubetzky:
In the phase of entrepreneurs,
there's three important phases.
One is the creative process,
which you clearly have done.
The second one
is the critic,
and the third
is a crusader.
The three C's.
That's great.
The creative, you've done.
The critic ‐‐ You need to be
your own worst critic.
You need to
figure out what is it
that is your competitor
to understand,
whether you really can
differentiate yourself
from the others.
And then, if you go through
that second phase,
then you go to the third phase,
and then you're the crusader,
and nobody's gonna stop you.
‐Yes.
But I feel like you skipped
the second phase.
Please explain to me
what differentiates you,
other than you being
a really great chemist.
Paiji Yoo: We have EPA‐approved
third‐party studies that show
that our products
were more effective ‐‐
Laboratory studies?
Laboratory studies.
Yeah, third party.
We outperformed all
of our leading competitors.
Guys, how much money
have you raised?
So, we've raised
$3 million.
‐What?!
‐At what valuation?
At a $13.5 million
valuation.
And who did you
raise it from?
A mix of venture capital
as well as
successful entrepreneurs
just like yourselves.
And you've been selling
for how long?
So, we've been live
for just over a month.
We've done $200,000
in sales.
Okay, that's not horrible.
So, today, we are 100%
direct‐to‐consumer
selling online.
However, we are launching
in a big‐box national retailer
at the beginning
of next year.
I don't think I like
that you have just
one tablet, one bottle.
I think when you see tablets,
you buy a bag
of dishwashing pellets,
and you get a whole bag of them,
like 36 in a bag.
So I feel like this needs
a strip with it
of a whole bunch of tablets.
It's much more appealing to a
customer that's looking at it.
Listening to Lori, I realize
that there's a piece of this
she understands
far better than I.
So I would propose,
without consulting with Lori,
that we invest
$1 million...
Whoa.
...for 25% of the company.
Herjavec: Whoa!
If you're willing ‐‐
If Lori wants in on it,
I'm in on it,
and if not,
I'm in on it by myself.
Every single mistake
that you're about to make,
we've probably made before,
and we're gonna be able to help
you prevent those mistakes.
And I really, really resonate
with your immigrant story.
I came from Mexico.
My father and my mother
didn't have a higher education.
And I was able to,
from nothing,
build a pretty successful
company ‐‐ Kind ‐‐
that is now
in 300,000 distribution points,
in every retailer
you want to be.
I think everything you've done
is really brilliant.
I'm a huge fan
of Kind Bars,
and I like your theory
of the word "kind."
Why did you
even put it as "kind"?
Because you wanted
to spread kindness
to the world
and do good things.
You know why
I put it on "kind"?
Because my father was liberated
by American soldiers
from a concentration camp,
and in spite
of horrible situations,
he always remembered...
Wow.
...not just the horrors,
but the kindness
that people showed to him
and helped him survive.
So it's in honor of,
in the tough moments,
always being kind to others.
Wow, that's a great story,
Daniel.
It is. Very.
I think you need a me.
I'm not happy to give them
even more money.
Are you in the deal
or not?
I'm gonna change the deal,
if Daniel's interested.
Well, while you change the deal,
I'm gonna make you an offer
that's probably more close to
what you actually wanted to do,
'cause I don't think
you're gonna sell 25% of
your company here today.
Alright.
What I'd like to do
is do $270,000 for 5%,
and I want
1% advisory shares,
because, frankly,
I bring a lot to the table.
There's only one Mr. Wonderful.
While you're
mulling that over
and while these guys are trying
to take 25% of your business,
let me tell you
where I'm at.
The product is easy to use.
Changing consumers' minds ‐‐
super‐hard.
I'm out.
Sorry to hear that.
Alright,
we've changed our offer.
We're gonna do $270,000
for 8%.
O'Leary: Ouch.
4% and 4% ‐‐
that's the offer.
What are you doing,
Mark?
Guys, look, I don't think
you really came here for a deal.
You came for the commercial.
I'm out.
But you still
have two offers.
My offer is $270,000 for 6%,
and the other
is $270,000 for 8%.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Sarah and Syed came in
seeking $270,000 for 2%
of their eco‐friendly cleaning‐
product company, Blueland.
Lori and Daniel have
offered $270,000 for 8%,
and Kevin has offered
$270,000 for 6%.
What do you want to do?
We can't give away
that much.
You guys know
as much as we do...
Shocking!
...that it is critical
for us to have a lean,
high‐growth business.
Do you have a counter
for any of us?
$270,000 at 3%.
Ooh! You guys
really didn't ‐‐
Oh, my gosh!
I would love the opportunity
just to say one more thing.
In the theme
of compromise,
I'll go to 5%
for the $270,000.
♪♪
[ Whispering ]
We're not going down.
It's, like, already too little.
♪♪
So, Kevin...
Yes?
...we know you like
a good royalty.
Oh!
What if we kept you at 3%
for $270,000
but then we give you
a royalty of 50 cents per kit
until you make
your money back?
♪♪
Done.
‐Whoo!
‐Oh, my God!
‐Congratulations.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Thank you so much!
‐Oh, my God! Ohh!
I'm really excited.
‐Great job, Sarah!
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Congrats.
‐Oh, my goodness.
‐Love it.
‐Ohh, my God!
The way we just started,
I thought there was no way
we'd walk away.
We got a Shark!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my goodness.
There's a woman
who understands me.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Lubetzky:
I was born in Mexico City ‐‐
one of four kids.
I lived there till I was 16,
and then we moved
to San Antonio, Texas.
My dad was a Holocaust survivor.
He was 15 1/2 when he was
liberated by American soldiers.
He immigrated to Mexico
after the war,
and that's where
he met my mom.
The way my dad shared his
experience about the Holocaust,
he didn't spare the horrible
details of what he went through,
but he also saw the world
through a prism of appreciation
and how the kindness of others
had helped him survive
through those dark periods
of history.
The first business
that I started after law school
is called PeaceWorks.
We bring neighbors
from conflict regions ‐‐
let's say Israelis,
Palestinians ‐‐
to work with one another
and build businesses together.
When they discover
each other's humanity,
it shatters
cultural stereotypes.
And when they have
profit interests,
it helps cement relationships.
When I was running PeaceWorks,
I was traveling all over,
and I was often skipping
lunch or dinner.
I needed a healthy snack
to keep me going,
and I couldn't find something
that I could feel good about
putting into my body.
And that's how the idea
for Kind came about.
The name "Kind"
is very much inspired
by my father's character.
And it is also being kind
to your body,
to your taste buds,
and to your world.
What made Kind different is,
first and foremost,
our obsession with quality.
We're using whole nuts,
whole fruits,
whole grains at all times.
Kind today is probably
recognized as the foremost
healthy‐snacking company
in the United States.
And it became one of the
fastest‐growing companies
in the entire U. S. economy.
I'm very proud
of what Kind has become ‐‐
not just because of the scale,
but because of what
it stands for.
And if my dad
is up there watching,
that's probably the part that
will give him the most meaning.
Guys, remember, it takes kind
and hungry values for us to win.
One of the secret ingredients
of America
is our belief
in the entrepreneurial system,
and what I love
about "Shark Tank"
is the ability
to foster this power.
If you're thinking
of entrepreneurship,
do not think that it's gonna be
the easier path.
It's probably gonna be the job
that you're gonna work
hardest in your life,
but you might not feel it
as much
because you're gonna love
what you're doing.
It's your baby,
and you're just gonna enjoy
every step of the way.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
what the entrepreneurs believe
is a solution
to a growing problem in America.
♪♪
My name
is Barrett Jacques,
and I'm from Nashville,
Tennessee.
And I'm Crom Carmichael,
also from Nashville, Tennessee.
The name of our company
is Minus Cal.
We're seeking $500,000
for 20% of the business.
Damn.
Now, 45 million Americans
go on a diet each year,
but the fact that 70% of adults
are either obese or overweight
means that something's
not working.
We need more lettuce
and fewer French fries.
That's easy to say,
harder to do,
and it's always
a lot less fun.
That's where Minus Cal
comes in,
a science‐based snack bar
and diet tablet
that block fat
when you eat it.
And how does Minus Cal
block fat?
So, imagine your digestive tract
is a party,
and our ingredient, the Choleve,
is the bouncer.
Herjavec: [ Laughs ]
When the fat shows up
at the party
without an invitation...
[ Greiner laughs ]
Choleve...
Cuban: Ohh!
...escorts the fat
out of the party
and out of your system,
keeping you from absorbing
those calories from fat.
It's that simple.
[ Laughs ]
And Choleve
is not a sketchy chemical.
Choleve is a proprietary,
all‐natural blend
coming from fermented tea.
That's our trade secret.
And we're able to put Choleve
in a variety of delicious foods.
Minus Cal is a great way
to lose weight
and to achieve
better health.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to have your cake
and eat it, too,
with Minus Cal?
Do we get samples?
I'm gonna give them
to you right now.
♪♪
‐Lori.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
‐Thank you so much.
‐You're very welcome.
Ohh!
Is this pill, like,
in "The Matrix"?
That's right ‐‐
one red one, one blue one.
One red, one blue?
If you take two of those pills
before a meal,
it will help
lowering cholesterol.
I've been taking the product
for about 12 years.
Doesn't taste great.
‐What?
‐Doesn't taste that great.
Can you walk us through
the Choleve again
and what is it?
You spoke it out very fast.
Sure.
Sounds like that's the essence
of your business.
Yeah, Choleve is
an all‐natural ingredient
that's derived
from fresh green tea.
And what we do is,
this particular molecule,
the active ingredient
in green tea ‐‐
we extract that
and we increase the potency
of that particular molecule
by 20 times.
How do you do that?
Explain to me, actually,
the result.
It'll do two things.
It will help lower
your cholesterol,
and we have a clinical trial
that we did 12 years ago.
It lowers cholesterol
17% to 20%.
And then our
chief science officer,
he went back and looked
at the test results
when he said
the evidence shows
that the people who took
our product versus the placebo
also lost weight.
And so, we went to the
University of Kansas,
and they came back to us
and said,
"What your product does
is it works
through
the lower intestines.
As it leaves the body,
it takes about 100 calories
worth of fat with it."
Is there anybody that should
avoid this product,
or is it safe
for everybody?
It is safe for everyone.
It's safe for everybody.
It's all natural.
That doesn't necessarily make it
safe for everybody.
But at the same time,
look, guys,
you know I'm a skeptic
on all this stuff.
Yeah.
You can't claim that it's gonna
reduce 100 calories
out of what you eat
by taking two pills.
‐We don't make that claim.
‐That's what he said.
We are gonna make the claim
that it's gonna block fat
at a percentage
dependent on the individual.
Your t‐shirts say
"Minus Cal."
That's 'cause that's the brand
name of the company.
When a consumer looks at it,
what do you think
he's gonna think?
Minus Cal.
Minus calories.
Right!
What is your strategy?
What is your distribution?
Minus cals!
Their strategy
is to make you think
that this is gonna
reduce your calories.
Mark,
let me ask my question.
[ Chuckles ]
How long has this product
been around?
We just launched.
I assume you have very little
sales. Is that right?
Correct.
That's correct.
Guys, I'm stunned
you guys are dealing
and asking these questions.
Do you sell it
to other people, too?
Do you guys realize
they just invented this product
out of nothing
and gave it a name?
Hold up. Hold up.
Here, if my understanding
is right...
I'm trying to understand
what I'm investing in, Mark.
...you have a bar that's
high‐fiber‐weight.
You're investing in air.
You have a bar that has
natural things in it.
You're saying ‐‐
Mark, it's not ‐‐
Mark, let me just say this.
Mark, Mark.
It's not air.
‐Yes, it is.
‐It's not air.
‐So, you took green ‐‐
‐Mark, Mark, let me say this.
I have the data
to back it up.
So, listen, if you want
to get out, get out,
but you're wrong.
No, I'm not wrong.
So, listen.
No, you are wrong.
You took
green‐tea extract, right,
and you invented
a product called Choleve.
No, it's not green‐tea
extract.
That's what you said.
I said it's derived
from green tea.
We take a particular
molecule.
We increase that concentration
by 20 times.
Because that green‐tea molecule
can lower your cholesterol
by 20%, right?
Yes.
Everybody knows that.
Everybody knows what?
So, listen, I find Mark's points
potentially persuasive,
but in my philosophy,
the way I like to eat
is ingredients you can see
and pronounce, real food,
and I feel nature,
over thousands of years,
has nurtured us in such ways
that we can just eat
the real stuff.
Best of luck to you,
but I'm out.
Here's where I'm at ‐‐
$500,000 for 20% of a startup
that has no revenue
is way too high.
You asked for too much.
You made a strategic error.
I'm out.
I don't know about Choleve,
and I know that it's dangerous
to claim that certain products
will do miraculous things,
like not have fat
stay in your body...
Okay, not ‐‐
...or whatever.
So I don't like to associate
with those things.
I have no problem with you,
but I'm out.
Look, I ‐‐
I'm so frustrated.
I have no idea. I really don't
know what your business is.
I don't know
what your strategy is.
I really
don't know anything.
Mark, sometimes your level of
arrogance really pisses me off.
Yeah, I ‐‐
And I ‐‐ Mark, let me ‐‐
And I'll only say that
you don't give people a chance.
I wish I knew
what their business was,
if you would let
people talk.
You know
what their product is, Robert.
Your level of arrogance
sometimes
just surrounds the room,
and you're a great guy ‐‐
I'll be respectful to you,
Robert.
I won't say
what I'm thinking.
It intimidates people.
And I'm just telling you,
you might be 100% right.
I just wish I had
the opportunity to hear it.
I know how hard people work
to get on that floor.
You know what's even harder,
Robert?
And you don't give them
a chance.
‐You know what's even harder?
‐I'm out.
♪♪
Let me ‐‐ Let me just say
one thing, please.
Neither one of us claimed
that if you take this product,
you'll lose weight.
Look at your shirt!
I said neither one of us
said we would lose weight.
Look at your shirt!
What does your shirt say?
It says fewer calories,
Mark.
Right.
How do you lose weight?
May I please finish?
We're not claiming that you're
going to lose weight.
We're saying that we are gonna
take some fat out of your body.
Now, I don't care
what you say.
I know what my science says,
and you're wrong.
You're just plain wrong.
That particular molecule,
that extract also will help you
on your weight.
It won't make you lose ‐‐
What did you just say?!
Let's ‐‐ Let's ‐‐
It won't make you lose weight.
It will help you.
It will help you lose
weight, but it won't
make you lose weight.
Actually, Crom,
now you're pissing me off.
[ Laughs ] You're digging
a deeper hole.
And I got to tell you, it's got
nothing to do with Mark.
You're kind of losing
credibility.
You just said
you're not ‐‐
You said
you're not losing weight.
What does it say
right here?
I will stand behind the fact
that the goal is to help ‐‐
Did you ‐‐ No, but ‐‐
Yeah. It's to help people
lose weight.
No, I am happy to say ‐‐
O'Leary: Okay, guys,
I think we're done here.
To everybody who's watching,
don't buy it.
I'm out.
Okay.
‐Thank you, gentlemen.
‐Thank you.
‐Go in peace.
♪♪
Jacques: Mark's never gonna
invest in a supplement.
Millions of people take
supplements.
It's like saying
to a personal trainer who says,
"I can help you lose weight,"
and then you hire him
and you don't lose any weight
that it was a scam.
That's not exactly fair
or logical.
Daniel, welcome to our very
dysfunctional family.
Mark, you beat the crap
out of these guys.
They deserve it!
But it's fair passion.
It's not fair.
That's my point.
Take the green tea
and chill!
Let's all hold hands.
‐I don't want to hold hands.
‐Family. Yes.
♪ Kumbaya ♪
Okay, I held your hand.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a product that began
as an elementary‐school project.
♪♪
Aloha, Sharks!
I'm Cassidy Crowley.
And I'm Lori Crowley,
Cassidy's mom.
And we're from Honolulu,
Hawaii.
I'm seeking $50,000 in exchange
for 50% of my company.
Greiner: Wow.
Sharks, I love to create
and invent.
When I was 7 years old,
my baby sister, Emily,
would always play
with her spoon.
Aww!
And my mom would always
get worried
that she might accidentally
poke or stab her throat.
So I wanted to create a product
that eliminated
that long and sharp design
of a traditional spoon.
So I invented
the Baby Toon.
The Baby Toon
is a combination
of a baby spoon
and a teether all in one.
The rectangular body
makes it easy for babies
to grasp and self‐feed.
The Baby Toon is made
of 100% soft silicone.
There are no sharp edges,
so it's gentle on babies' gums,
and it works great
for teething.
Sharks, all parents know
that babies love
throwing their spoons
on the floor.
Well, we have a solution
for this.
Just put a pacifier clip
around the Baby Toon...
‐Ohh!
‐Cool!
...and attach it
to the baby's shirt.
No more baby spoons getting
thrown on the floor!
But wait! There's more!
[ Laughter ]
Baby Toon is made
right here in the USA,
and it was designed
and created by me.
So, Sharks, who's ready to take
a bite out of the Baby Toon?
Both: Together,
we can bring Baby Toons
to every baby in the world.
‐Nice!
‐Wow!
‐Good job, Cassidy!
‐That was great!
Greiner: Oh, my gosh.
So, we have some samples we'd
like to pass out to you, Sharks.
How old was Cassidy?
I'm 10.
She's 10.
Herjavec: 10 going on 34.
Oh, are we gonna eat?
[ Laughs ]
This is for Lori.
‐That's for me?
‐Yep.
Okay.
‐Should I feed Lori?
‐[ Laughs ]
We've brought ‐‐
from Hawaii, we have poi,
which is a Hawaiian
baby food.
Greiner: How did you come up
with the design?
And what did you do
to figure that out?
So, in first grade,
I entered a local science fair
when I was 7 years old.
And we have, actually,
my sample,
if you guys want
to see it.
We do.
Oh, wow.
So, that's your prototype?
Yeah, this is the one
that I made in first grade.
Look at this.
I mean, partially why
I'm just very thankful I'm here
is I want to show other kids
that they can be open
to opportunities
they have at school
or even at home
to create and invent.
I just really hope
I inspire them.
It's a dream come true.
So, are you selling it already,
or is it ‐‐
Yeah,
we sell our product.
So, since September of 2018,
we had $5,000 in sales.
‐Wow!
‐Thank you.
What does it cost?
Our total cost is $6.60.
And you sell it
for how much?
We sell it for $15.
‐$15?
‐Good for you!
Cassidy, are you gonna be
a superstar at your school
because you were on
"Shark Tank"?
Well, that's obviously
not why I'm here.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, even better answer!
Oh, my God,
I love you!
Cassidy, it's pretty rare
that somebody comes in here
and offers us 50%.
Why did you do that?
I mean, let's face it.
I'm only 10 years old.
I need a partner.
I mean, I still have to go
to high school.
I think you're more of a Shark
than we are.
Cassidy, you've done
an amazing, amazing job.
I mean, it's incredible...
Thank you.
...to have started a business,
to develop a product,
to see it through,
to make your way here.
I mean, just ‐‐ I can't even
imagine what's next for you.
The challenge I have is just,
it's really not a fit for me.
So I'm out,
but great, great job, Cassidy.
Cassidy, I've been doing little
businesses since I was a kid.
I can already tell
from your presence,
from your poise,
from your grit
that you're gonna go
very, very far.
This was three years ago,
and you didn't give up.
You know, manufacturing
can be very tricky.
I find it fascinating
that you pulled this off.
Well, actually, just recently,
we had to change our durometer
of silicone we're using,
so we had to lower it.
You had to change what?
Change the durometer
of silicone.
What's a durometer?
Durometer is how you measure
the firmness of silicone.
For example,
if you have something
that's a higher
durometer ‐‐
Who are you, lady?
[ Laughing ] Exactly!
If you have something
that's a higher durometer
of silicone, it's gonna be
more stiff and hard.
And if you have something
that's a lower durometer
of silicone,
it's gonna be more flexible.
Cassidy,
do you have a patent on it?
Yeah, we have our patents
right here, actually.
Wow!
Cassidy,
I am beyond impressed.
I know you're not allowed
to do this
in the United States of America,
but if in 20 years,
you want to marry one
of my kids...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...I'd be very delighted.
But in all seriousness,
you're so impressive.
But I don't understand
the baby space,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much.
Cassidy, I'm torn
because I don't feel
that you're willing
to quit elementary school.
But I can go straight
to college.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I don't want you to
quit school.
It's a little early.
I'm out.
Cassidy,
this is a great product.
You just absolutely
blow me away.
You said you always wanted
to go on "Shark Tank,"
and I'm so proud
if we had any part
in your wanting
to become an entrepreneur.
So, guess what, young lady.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
‐Yay!
Because I have to be along
with this journey.
I'm giving you $50,000
for 50%.
Herjavec: Wow.
Lori...
you have a deal.
‐Congratulations.
‐Yay!
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you!
You are just amazing!
Amazing!
‐We are so excited.
‐Thank you.
High five.
‐Aww!
‐I'll see you soon.
Congrats, guys.
Well done.
Cassidy, before you leave,
come up here,
sit in the Shark chair.
‐Oh, yes!
‐That's where you're going.
Let's see you.
♪♪
How does it feel?
Yay, Cassidy!
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
Cassidy, look at Kevin and say,
"You're dead to me."
[ Laughter ]
‐Congrats, Cassidy.
‐Thank you!
[ Laughs ]
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Bye!
‐Thank you!
Oh, my gosh!
I can't believe
we got a deal!
Lubetzky: What's fascinating
about "Shark Tank"
is I have four kids,
my youngest is 6 years old,
and she gets glued
to the TV.
It's a very engaging platform.
Isn't that amazing?
It's amazing.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a convenient version
of a traditional
Middle Eastern snack.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is John Sorial.
I'm from Washington, D. C.
And I'm seeking
a $300,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in my product.
Sharks, being the son
of Egyptian immigrants,
I loved the East Mediterranean
foods I grew up on.
The problem is, my grandmother
didn't ship nationwide.
So I took authentic recipes
from the motherland
and gave them
a fresh, new taste and look
with TaDah! Foods.
TaDah! is a frozen line
of products
that brings one of the world's
most popular dishes, falafel,
to the masses.
Falafel is
an amazingly savory blend
of chickpeas, aromatic herbs,
fresh veggies, and spices.
Mmm!
And we've made it super‐easy
and convenient to enjoy
with our Falafel Street Wraps.
In just three minutes,
you can say goodbye
to bland, boring bean burritos
and finally eat something
that's bursting with flavors.
And that's not all.
For those looking
to eat gluten‐free,
we created the world's first
and only stuffed falafel popper.
That's right.
I took
the already‐perfect falafel
and I figured out how
to stuff it on the inside
with one of our creamy
signature dips.
So, Sharks,
who wants to help me
take America
on an exotic culinary journey
of deliciously prepared
plant‐based foods
ready to heat and eat
any time of day?
‐Bring it.
‐Yeah.
‐Want to eat?
‐Feed us, John! Feed us!
So, it's a falafel ball?
Well, there's two lines
of products.
Are they all the same?
‐No.
‐Thank you.
‐Lori.
So, what you guys have there,
from left to right ‐‐
you have two versions
of our best‐selling
Falafel Street Wrap.
The first one ‐‐
that's our Sweet‐n‐Spicy
Harissa with Lebni.
Wow.
This is really good.
That second one is
the Lemon Roasted Garlic Hummus.
‐Oh.
‐Very nice.
And then
you have the Poppers.
It's Harissa Hummus,
Cucumber Dill Yogurt,
and our original
Hummus flavor.
John, this feels very fresh,
like it was made a minute ago.
Thank you so much.
Is it made a minute ago,
or is it from the package
and is it refrigerated,
frozen?
That has been sitting on the
shelf somewhere in a retail ‐‐
I actually bought it off
the shelf and brought it here.
Really?
So I don't know
the manufacture date on it,
but, you know,
we get about an 18‐month
shelf life on our product.
Well,
that's very reassuring.
In the refrigerated set
or in the frozen set?
In the frozen set.
This is a frozen product.
It's chickpea, right?
Chickpea‐based, yes.
Tell us about
your background.
My parents are immigrants.
They actually left Egypt.
There was some religious
persecution that was happening.
They came to America.
And when you're the son
of immigrant parents,
they're really liberal
and open‐minded,
as long as you take
a profession in medicine,
engineering, law,
or medicine, right?
[ Laughter ]
And so, I studied
chemical engineering
at Johns Hopkins University.
I graduated.
I worked in oil refining.
I traveled
all over the world.
But I found it to be
a really hollow experience.
You know, it just wasn't
a passion of mine.
What do you sell it for,
and what is the cost?
The 7 1/2‐ounce
Falafel Street Wraps
retail for $3.99,
and the 8‐ounce bag of
the gluten‐free Falafel Poppers
retails for $4.99.
Costs me $1.09.
Hey, John, it says here you give
25% of your profits to charity.
25% of distributed profits
from the original founders
is going
to not‐for‐profits.
So, does that mean ‐‐
A specific one, or...?
Well, yes, we have a few,
but the biggest one
works with
impoverished children.
They try to break
the poverty cycle
through education, medical care,
and food programs.
O'Leary: Break down
the numbers for me.
Lifetime sales
is over $8.2 million.
Wow!
Trailing 12 months
is $1 million.
And the year before that?
$1 million.
You've stayed steady
at $1 million.
So you're flat.
Yeah, we're flat
because demand is there
and we just ‐‐
we can't supply it.
We were the fastest‐growing
frozen brand in the country.
And then...
And then we ran into
a big production issue.
Aha.
And so then we went
from 2.3 to 1.7,
and now we're at 1.
What happened?
You were using
a co‐packer?
Yeah, so,
it was fantastic.
We were achieving
great margins with them.
They became
financially insolvent.
‐You couldn't make product.
‐I couldn't make product.
I would show up, and they'd have
four people on the floor.
This takes dozens of people,
right?
Wow.
So, I would stay all night
with the staff.
I would suit up, and I was
shoveling chickpeas myself.
But at the same time, I was
flying all over the country
trying to source
new co‐packers.
We fixed that problem.
On this million of sales
in the last 12 months...
‐Yeah.
‐...how much did you lose?
Say, 2018,
we lost $200,000.
The more you're talking,
I'm less excited.
When you first came out, I was
like, "Whoo! Falafel!"
‐Let's get you more excited.
‐Alright.
We are in the top 10 of
all frozen products nationwide,
and we were the fastest‐growing
in the frozen natural space.
Not anymore.
You're flat.
You know, hearing your story
resonates to me,
but I think there are some
other Sharks on the panel here
that can help
accelerate you faster.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
So, how much
have you invested,
and have you taken in
any outside investors?
So, we've only ever done
a friends and family round.
The total round was $300,000.
How much equity did you have to
give up for the $300,000?
I gave away 75%.
‐You own 25%?
‐Yes.
You gave up 75?
Sorry ‐‐ you gave up 75%
at the beginning?
Okay, so, that's a lot,
and that has a lot of
implications, right?
Sure. Originally, it was 50%,
right, to the investors.
And I had the other 50%.
So, then,
what we ended up doing was,
the other investors
were like,
"No, we want to be
part of the giving," okay?
So we then distributed that 25%
that was reserved
for the social causes, and we
distributed amongst all of us.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
That doesn't make sense.
Sorry. Hang on.
You're giving up
25% of the equity
to the social causes,
not of the profits?
Correct.
Oh, John. John.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
and the other Sharks
are concerned
about the business structure
of John's
frozen falafel company, TaDah!
You're giving up
25% of the equity
to the social causes,
not of the profits?
Correct.
Oh, John. John.
Whoa.
Maybe I'm not doing a good job
of explaining this.
The investors ‐‐
the four investors ‐‐
myself and the other three
investors ‐‐ or founders ‐‐
own 100% of the company.
Okay. Alright.
And in each
of our own equity stake,
we've pledged
25% of what we make
to these charities.
John, look, here you are facing
an inventory shortage.
Why didn't your investors
loan you more?
Our total liability's
$445,000.
That's why they're not
loaning you more money.
John, sometimes
you love the singer...
Yeah.
...but you hate the song.
Well, I'll sing you
a different song.
[ Laughter ]
No, listen, seriously.
I wish you luck,
but this isn't for me.
I'm out.
O'Leary: John, look,
the food's great.
As we peel the onion
on your story, oh, my goodness!
Ugh!
The cap table, it doesn't need
cosmetic surgery.
It needs major surgery.
No, it doesn't.
He re‐explained it.
It was okay.
What do you mean?
It's four investors.
It's misalignment.
No, no, no, he just ‐‐
Let me finish, Mark.
I mean,
it's too much work for me.
I'm sorry, my friend.
Food's great.
I really don't see it
as that much ‐‐
I'm out. I'm out.
It's just ‐‐
It's too much work.
Daniel, I'm betting,
in the journey of Kind,
you faced this problem
somewhere along the road.
What does this guy
have to do?
Lubetzky: Um...
Kind,
when it was born...
Yeah?
...we were in a situation
not very dissimilar to yours.
Right.
I'd lost
about $1 million in sales
because one of our manufacturers
had changed the ingredients.
And we were this far away
from just closing everything.
Yeah.
And it's fascinating to me
when I think back
that Kind grew out of the one of
the toughest years of my life,
and out of that darkness
came incredible light,
and Kind today sells
in 300,000 stores,
over $1 billion a year
in retail.
And so it can happen.
And when I think about you and
I see how you haven't given up
after every single thing
that has hit you...
Correct.
...I just want to understand
what's motivating you.
Why haven't you just gone back
to being an engineer?
What does this mean
to you?
It's perspective, right?
When you go to other parts
of the world
and you see
how people live, right,
you realize
that there are ‐‐
People are fighting
for their lives.
That's why I'm not ‐‐ Like, I
want to be a profitable company,
and I've worked really hard,
and we ‐‐
[ Sighs ]
[ Voice breaking ]
And it has been difficult.
But I think about my family
and those people
who are struggling.
And I want ‐‐
I want this to be a success
because...
it'll impact their lives.
I'm sorry.
[ Sniffles ]
I've never cried like that.
I'm sorry.
[ Sniffles, groans ]
[ Sniffles ]
And I understand
you think it's complex
because we've been
through a lot,
but it just means that I know
how to keep our company going.
You have someone who has proven
themself, who's scaled it,
has the team,
has the manufacturing.
We just want to succeed.
Your story resonates a lot
with me, as I said earlier,
and you have an
incredibly quality product...
Thank you.
...and you have
an incredible passion,
but you have a mess
in terms of the system
that you have
that needs to be fixed.
So I don't see how with
$300,000, you get out of it.
You just need
a little bit more.
So if you want the $300,000,
I'll do it for 20%.
‐Wow.
‐Okay.
Or I'll give you
half a million dollars for 25%
so that we can
do this properly.
Okay.
‐Wow.
And if we do any of the ‐‐
the bigger option,
that money
would be to buy out
a portion
or all of your investors
because I'm gonna be doing
all of the work with you,
so I want you to derive
the benefits.
Okay.
I actually
would like to get you
to a bigger stake
than you currently have.
Can we do $500,000 at 25%
but with then a line of credit
for accounts receivable
for another half million?
I will do the $500,000
for 25%,
and I will most likely
give you a line of credit,
but it's not
part of this deal.
I'm gonna sit down with you
and your investors...
Sure.
...and review the $400,000‐some
that they're owed,
the equity that they have,
and then, as part
of our next negotiation,
I will be happy to provide maybe
a $1 million line of credit,
whatever is necessary.
That's amazing.
But it will have
to be part of the ‐‐
Before you jump,
two of the people ‐‐
or three people,
potentially ‐‐
that have been there with you
since the beginning,
he wants to try
to buy out.
Greiner: John. John.
With fair terms.
You've been
through the wars,
and when somebody is
in a foxhole with you...
Yes.
...you don't
buy them out, right?
That's exactly right.
But, from what I understand,
that's an option.
No, you said
your investors signaled
that they're willing
to do whatever it takes.
Right now, the investors
are dying to just
get their money back.
You don't know that, though.
You don't know that.
Well, it's pretty obvious
from the numbers.
What valuation are you buying
them out at, right?
Just going back and saying,
"Is there a price
to buy you out at?"
means, "I think
it's gonna go up in value,
and I'm not taking you
for the ride," right?
"I think I can create more value
than I'm gonna pay you."
Otherwise, you wouldn't
buy them out, right?
You don't always know that,
Mark.
Yeah, of course.
Maybe they just want
to get some cash out.
To Mark's point, my partners ‐‐
they're my friends.
They believed in me
when it was just a concept.
So, as long as this is not,
like, some type of takeover...
What about this, John?
John, John.
John. John, this is
a tremendous opportunity.
I'll give you $300,000
for 20% ‐‐ less than his ‐‐
but I'll give you
another $500,000 line of credit.
So now there's two offers.
You both are icons
in your respective industries.
Is there any way to structure
a deal with both of you?
Lubetzky:
I just want to make clear
that I'm doing this
to give you a hand.
I know you are.
I don't do charity.
I want you to win,
but the terms that I'm offering
are very generous.
Herjavec: John,
you got to make a decision.
You have to decide.
What are you gonna do?
Would you do half a million
for 20%?
No.
♪♪
I feel extremely blessed,
and, Daniel,
I accept your offer.
Greiner: Whoo!
[ Applause ]
We're gonna
kill it together.
We're definitely
gonna kill it.
We're gonna make falafel
the sexiest food on Earth.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Unbelievable.
Sexy falafel.
That was a good one,
Daniel.
Oh, my God.
Choosing between Daniel and Mark
was one of the most difficult
decisions I've ever made,
but Daniel is an icon
in our industry.
To have him in our corner,
supporting us
not just financially,
but, like, working with us
and helping us to grow TaDah!
into what we hope
to be a national brand,
it's just the best outcome
I could have hoped for.
♪♪